le prélèvement de l'impôt à la source
l'idée n'a rien de nouveau
les politiques de tous bords long
dégainer sans parvenir à l'appliquer
jusqu'au 1er janvier 2019 en 1970 et
valéry giscard d'estaing pas encore
président l'envisager face à la montée
des salaires et des ménages imposables
l'a peut-être où la technique de la
retenue à la source ou au contraire la
technique du paiement mensuel volontaire
de l'impôt confiée à un organisme qui
peut être employeur de tout temps
plusieurs freins à cette mesure les
régimes spéciaux intermittents et
professions libérales aux revenus très
fluctuant l'année blanche due à la fin
des impôts prélevés sur l'année
précédente
la teinte présumées à la vie privée avec
l'accès aux informations du foyer ouvert
aux employeurs et la crainte d'une
demande d'augmentation des salaires en
masse pour autant en 1990 55 % des
français sont en faveur du prélèvement à
la source en l'éternelle question refait
surface et comme toujours en pareil cas
on reparle du prélèvement à la source et
suivent les promesses politiques le
contribuable et le salarié aura donc
tous les mois le le disponibles il
n'aura plus à a essayé de mettre de côté
si on peut simplifier au travers du prêt
les moins sûrs c'est un objectif et
c'est un engagement capri président de
la république hier soir
cet engagement est repris par emmanuel
macron 2018 alors que quasiment tous les
pays occidentaux appliquent parfois
depuis un siècle comme au canada
en france patience même si certains
contribuables sont déjà soumis ceux qui
travaillent derrière la frontière
j'ai pas planifié mon budget sur l'année
je sais de toute façon ce qu'il me reste
le sait exactement ce qu'il me reste à
la fin du mois alors qu'en france on est
obligé de garder une petite somme
pour pouvoir payer les impôts après de
longues interrogations et hésitations le
prélèvement à la source entre en vigueur
le 1er janvier 2019 avec les faveurs de
65% des français
[Musique]